So we've been talking about transit.
And I want to say a couple things more just to round out that discussion.
Uh,
Yoko,
recall how this works.
Trantis.
Uh,
you get light,
uh,
blocked light from the star blocked by the planet.
Uh,
and in order for this to occur,
the orbit has to be exactly edge on,
otherwise the planet doesn't actually get in the way between you and the star.
So must be edge on.
And so what you see basically a,
although you're too far away to see it in this kind of detail,
it looks something like this.
Here's a star.
It's got this,
uh,
big bright shining desk.
And then,
uh,
crossing that star is a darker desk
from the planet.
So it looks like you have,
you know,
a little,
little spot there and it's clear just from the geometry of this situation,
how much light is obscured.
Uh,
it's basically the ratio of the cross section of the,
uh,
planet to that,
of the star.
So the depth of the transit.
And by that I mean,
uh,
you know,
the fraction of the light that is obscured,
uh,
is equal to,
that will be,
uh,
the cross section of the planet
divided by the Cross section of the star.
And the Cross section is just the projected area.
And so,
uh,
what that means in practice is here's the radius of the star,
and there's an equivalent radius of the planet and it's just the ratio of the
projected areas.
Now,
the area of a circle projected area of a sphere is a circle.
The area of a circle you probably remember from a geometry is Pi r squared.
And so what this is going to be is a Pi are of the planet squared divided by Pi
r of the star squared and the pis cancel.
So it's the ratio of the squares of the radio.
Hi.
Okay.
So,
uh,
to take an example,
supposing you were,
you were an astronomer in some distant place and you're looking at the,
uh,
I add our own solar system and you're fortunate enough to be in a place where
you can see our solar system edge.
On,
what would you see when the earth,
it's the sun.
So,
uh,
the earth.
So here's an example.
Uh,
earth transmitting the sun,
Sun,
the radius of the earth,
it turns out is something like seven times 10 to the six meters.
Uh,
the radius of the sun is about a hundred times that seven times 10 to the eight
meters.
And so the depth of such a,
uh,
of such a transit is,
the square of the ratios of these,
uh,
of these radio guy,
seven times 10 to the six,
seven times 10 to the eight
squared,
that's 10 to the minus two squared is equal to 10 to the minus four or 0.01%.
So that's a lot less than what you found in,
uh,
in section yesterday for a Jupiter like planets.
And the key is in this,
uh,
r squared factor until the earth is about a 10th,
has about a 10th.
The radius is about a 10th the size of Jupiter,
but that 10th gets squared.
So that's a hundred.
And so instead of getting a 1%,
uh,
dip in the light or approximately 1%,
you get a one 100th of 1%,
one 100,
1% is 10 to the minus two,
one 100th of 10 of 1% is 10 to the minus four.
So as the planet gets smaller,
uh,
you,
it becomes harder and harder to see these transits.
And if you think back on the pictures of these light curve,
the graphs that were made,
uh,
in,
from in the observations from the ground,
you really needed to have about a 1% dip in order to be able to see it from
space.
You can do a lot better.
Things are much more stable and you might well be able to see something like
this,
but only from space and not necessarily from the ground.
Uh,
now,
uh,
having done this little calculation,
of course in real life,
you do it backwards.
Uh,
what I did here was I assumed that I knew what the radius is and I calculated
what the transit would be.
That isn't how it works with extra solar planets.
Because of course you don't know what the radius is a and instead what happens
is you see the transit and you see the transit and you work backwards to figure
out what the radius is.
You have to make some assumption about what the radius of the star is likely to
be.
Uh,
and so basically observing a Trenton is a way to get the radius of the star.
So if Trent,
it,
uh,
give you the radius,
and this is nice because the radio velocity met method,
the doppler shift method,
doppler measurement also give you something about,
uh,
the star,
but it's the mass,
not the radius.
And then if you have both of these things,
then you get to put them together and figure out what the density is.
And that's why observing both of these things,
uh,
in the same system is so useful.
Uh,
so let's do this again.
For the earth,
the mass of the earth is six times 10 to the 24 kilograms.
The radius of the earth,
we just figured out seven times 10 to the six meters.
And our hypothetical astronomers out there,
uh,
in the rest of the galaxy somewhere,
would have been able to determine this if they saw the transit.
So now,
uh,
what is the density density is this Greek letter row symbolically,
and that is equal to mass over volume,
uh,
which is equal to mass over four thirds.
Pi r cubed pies equal to three,
so that cancels,
which is helpful.
Uh,
and let's see,
uh,
so the mass on top six times 10 to the 24 divided by four times this quantity
cubed.
Now what do we do about that?
Seven Times seven is 50,
right?
Uh,
so this is seven times 50,
which is 350.
Uh,
so let's see.
This is equal to six times 10 to the 24 over four times 350 times 10 to the six
cubed,
which is 10 to the 18,
six times three is 18.
Uh,
and so what's this?
Oh,
I don't know.
This is 1400.
Uh,
and so this then in turn is equal to six times 10 to the 24 over 1.4 times 10 to
the 21.
Uh,
because,
uh,
this is 1.4 times 10 to the three times 10 to the 18,
six over 1.4 is four.
Give or take a times 10 to the three.
And that's the answer.
That's the density in what unit.
Let's see.
Uh,
this had better be kilograms per meter cube.
Dritan mks calculation.
Why?
Because that's what I started with kilograms in meters four times 10 to the
three kilograms per meter cube.
What does that tell you?
Four times more dense than water.
Excellent.
Uh,
so,
uh,
this is four times water.
Water is defined to be a tented,
the three kilograms per meter cubed density of water or rather a kilogram is
defined.
So that water has that particular density.
Um,
it's four times water,
uh,
that makes it a rocky planet because,
the ices and the gases that make up a atypical,
uh,
a typical gas giant planet don't,
don't get,
don't achieve that kind of density.
And so,
uh,
our hypothetical astronomers observing transit would determine not only that the
earth that the earth is there,
but also that it's gotta be made out of rocks.
And that,
uh,
is an additional piece of information that's really useful and trying to figure
out what's going on in these kinds of systems.
Okay.
Now it turns out that there are some other methods for identifying planets
around other stars.
Uh,
and I want to talk about one of them.
And the reason I hadn't talked about this one more is because it hasn't yet
discovered any planets around other stars.
There've been lots of planets discovered by the radio velocity method.
There've been lots of planets discovered,
uh,
now by transits now with the latest Hubble space telescope results.
Uh,
but that those were not the first methods that were,
were tried for a long time.
People had been trying something else and it hasn't really worked.
And this is,
uh,
this is called astrometry.
So here's another method.
Okay.
Astrometry means measuring stars in Greek.
Uh,
and,
uh,
basically what this is,
is it's determining the positions of stars to extremely high accuracy.
Remember the whole game here is that the star moves to,
and we've been using doppler shift measurements to measure the velocity of the
star,
the radio velocity of the stars that goes round and round.
But you could in principle also try and figure out,
uh,
that the actual position of the stars in space moves a little bit too.
So,
uh,
observing a change in position
of the star.
Now that change is quite small a,
and you'll recall that we started out a few weeks ago saying,
you know,
you don't see the star all that accurately because at atmospheric distortion and
prob optical problems in your telescope,
you just see this big blob of light.
And the key point here is that it is actually not,
if you have enough light,
uh,
you can determine the center of a big Blob of like,
really quite accurately determine
the center
okay.
Of a blob of light
to a much greater accuracy
then the extent of the blob.
So,
you know,
I take a picture of a star and I see something that kind of looks like this,
and that's big and ugly and hard to deal with,
except,
uh,
you know,
the accuracy of the position of that Blob isn't limited by the extent,
that the centers somewhere around here,
and if that blob were to move slightly so that the center,
uh,
took a little s went around in circles like this,
you'd actually be able to see that as this big blob sort of move slowly around.
And that's the,
that's the trick with astrometry.
So you do these repeated measurements of the precise position of the star,
uh,
and you want to be able to see it going around in circles.
So,
uh,
we have in fact all the equations we need to deal with this already.
Um,
and,
uh,
so let's just,
let's just go straight to a particular exercise,
a calculation,
uh,
how big a change
in the son's position,
uh,
due to the planet Jupiter,
because that's the most massive and we'll make the most difference.
Uh,
what'd you see if you're on Alpha Centaury Wood and Alpha Centaury astronomer
observe.
So here's the situation.
You're sitting on Alpha Centaury,
you're looking back,
which is the nearest star you may recall,
uh,
you're looking back at the solar system and you're hoping to see the change in
movement of the sun,
uh,
due to the presence of the planet Jupiter.
So the first thing to say about this is,
uh,
what do we mean by change in position?
Change in position.
What we're talking about is an angle.
We talked about this in a different context before.
Here's The Observer.
Here's,
here's the,
uh,
the star and the star is moving.
It's going to move up to here.
And what we want is to draw this triangle and we want an angle,
uh,
and then,
[inaudible] over here is the amount by which the star moves.
Do one over here is the distance to the star.
And we want the angular
change in position because that's what we mean when we make a position
measurement,
uh,
in space.
Okay?
So that's the first thing is to understand what the answer ought ought to look
like.
It's got to be some kind of an angle.
And then the second thing is,
I've done my usual trick here of not giving you a whole bunch of information
that you're going to need.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
the,
the first thing you have to do in order to,
uh,
line up,
of the try and set up the answer is you have to figure out some,
some actual answers.
So the mass of the sun is obviously equal to the mass of the sun.
That's easy.
Uh,
the mass of Jupiter is equal to a two times 10 to the 27 kilograms that a one
1000th of the mass of the sun.
Uh,
the distance from Alpha sin to us son from Alpha sent to the sun is about one
parsec.
I think I mentioned that before.
Uh,
because it,
this is the closest star that there is.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the semi major axis of Jupiter's orbit a is equal to five astronomical units.
I wrote that down on the first day of class.
So you're going to need all this information.
Now here's the trick.
Here's Jupiter doing it's five astronomical unit thing.
Uh,
and then the sun in the middle.
Here's the center of mass,
center of mass,
okay.
And The sun is,
uh,
doing a little circuit,
in the other direction,
always making sure that it's on the other side of the center of mass from the
planet.
That's what a center of mass means,
right?
Uh,
and,
uh,
then we can take
at one point,
here's the,
let's say,
here's The sun and here's Jupiter.
And we take this little line here.
And,
uh,
the whole of the distance here is a total.
And the distance from the planet to the center of mass is a planet.
And this tiny little distance here is a star.
And what we need to look for is a star in this case,
because we're watching the star go round in circles,
not the planet.
And then the usual equations apply where m star a star is equal to an planet,
a planet.
We've seen this equation in dealing with velocities.
Uh,
but it's the same thing in distances because the,
the time that it takes to go around these circles,
uh,
is one orbital period is the same in both cases.
So if the velocity is slower than you cover less ground,
uh,
or to put it a different way,
if you're going in a smaller circle,
you're not moving as fast.
So it's the same equation.
And so let's do this.
A star is equal to an planet over m star times a of the planet.
That's five.
Aau in the case of,
in this particular case,
and I've already said that the mass of the planet,
uh,
is equal to 10 to the minus three times the mass of the star here.
So this is 10 to the minus three.
So this is five times 10 to the minus three astronomical units.
That's how far the earth,
that's,
that's the radius of the sun's orbit around,
uh,
around the center of mass with Jupiter.
You want to think of it that way?
Uh,
but that's not the answer we want.
We want an angle,
uh,
and this in a u and this here in parsecs will give us an angle in arc seconds.
And this is a particularly easy one.
We already have five times 10 to the minus three in Aau and the distance is one
parsec.
And so this is five times 10 to the minus three arc seconds,
five milli arc seconds.
Now,
that's much smaller than the size of the blob of light from Alpha Centauri.
But as I said,
uh,
you can see the motion of the center of a Blob of light to fairly high accuracy
and this is a pretty readily observable.
Yeah.
So folks sitting on Alpha Centaury would know that the,
uh,
who have our kind of,
our level of technology would already know that Jupiter exists from this method.
Interestingly,
uh,
we can look at Alpha Centuri,
right?
Uh,
you can do this backwards and you get exactly the same answer because Alpha
Centaury is a sunlike star has exactly the same mass and we don't observe any
such motion in Alpha Sam.
And so there is no Jupiter like planets around Alpha Sam.
Uh,
we know that because if there had been,
we would have seen it through this mess.
It's through,
through this method.
Yeah.
Uh,
no,
you can do the same thing.
Let me do it quickly.
Uh,
for the earth.
Supposing you want to detect the earth in this way.
So,
uh,
a of the planet,
so this is for earth.
Uh,
a of the planet is now one a u instead of five,
eight use mass of the planet is six times 10 to the 24.
So mass of the planet over a mass of the star is six times 10 to the 24,
over two times 10 to the 30,
that three times 10 to the minus six.
And so,
uh,
the,
a of the sun due to the earth now not due to Jupiter is equal to one a you,
that's uh,
the,
the uh,
the size of the planet times the ratio of the masses,
which is three times 10 to the minus six.
So it's three times 10 to the minus six a you much less than for Jupiter,
which was five times 10 to the minus three a.
And then Alpha Equals d two over d one,
three times 10 to the minus six over one,
three micro arc seconds.
Okay.
This is not observable,
at least not with current technology.
So our friends on Alpha Centaury who know that they're stupid or don't yet know
that Earth exists,
uh,
because this is so much smaller than the effect due to due to Jupiter and its
smaller for two different reasons.
One reason is that the mass of earth is small,
so this ratio is small.
The other is that the Earth's orbit is shorter.
Uh,
so it's one a u instead of five Aau.
So you're multiplying two numbers together.
Instead of multiplying five by 10 to the minus three,
you're multiplying one by 10 to the minus six.
And so both of those numbers are smaller and so the effect is that much smaller.
So we can't yet,
uh,
our friends on Alpha Santori can't tell whether we have earth.
Uh,
and likewise,
we can't tell whether Alpha Centaury,
uh,
has,
has an earth.
So one of the interesting things about the astrometry method,
and this is why I bring the whole thing up,
is that it favors big orbits.
The bigger the orbit,
the bigger the f the,
the motion of both the star and the planet.
This is exactly opposite to what happens with the radio velocity method.
Radio philosophy method favors small orbits because in small orbits,
things go faster and you're looking at the velocity.
So this favors big orbits,
and that's the opposite of radial velocity measurement.
Uh,
and it also,
uh,
favors massive planet.
The more massive the planet that the better off you'll be,
which is the same as the radio velocity method.
Okay?
And so this is useful,
one of the,
if you're trying to figure out what kinds of things are out there,
it's helpful to be looking with several different methods which select for
different kinds of objects that you can look for.
And so,
uh,
you can call these selection effects and,
you know,
if you're looking at radio velocities,
you can miss all the,
all the large orbit stars.
And so it would be nice to also look with astrometry so that you can,
uh,
see,
see other kinds of stars,
uh,
other kinds of planets.
Now let's see.
The astrometry method has one other feature that,
uh,
it need star needs to be,
needs to be nearby.
This is a fee.
This isn't a question that doesn't arise in radio velocity and it's because of
this term.
It's because you're,
it's because of this term here.
You're looking for Alpha.
So even once you figured out how much the star moves,
uh,
you've got to divide by the distance of the star.
So for example,
if you're looking at something 10 parsecs away instead of one parsec away,
then you've got only one 10th the effect.
And so while people sitting on Alpha Centaury can see the effect of Jupiter
people 10 times further away,
a on some other star,
a,
which is still quite close and galactic terms would not be able to see that
exact same effect.
Even though of course,
the sun's moving the same way,
regardless of who's looking at it.
The further away you get,
the smaller the effect becomes.
That's why nobody's largely,
I think that's,
nobody has successfully used the astrometry effect cause it's only works out
well on very nearby stars and there's just a limited number of those to look at.
Uh,
and so let me summarize all these different methods now.
oh good.
Uh,
by,
uh,
just making a little table of the so called selection effects.
These are what kinds of things are easy to see.
Uh,
and what kinds of things are not so easy to see for a given method.
And we've got three different methods.
So let's make a little table here.
Method.
Uh,
what kinds of orbits get picked out,
what kind of planets get picked out for a given or a bid and other
considerations.
Uh,
and here we go.
So the first one we talked about was radial velocities.
This is the doppler shift.
And this picks out short or small orbits short.
If you're thinking about the period small,
if you're thinking about the semi major axis,
uh,
because the,
the smaller the orbit,
the faster the planet it has to go.
And therefore,
the faster the star has to respond,
uh,
it picks out massive planets because the more massive the planet,
the greater the reflex motion of the star.
And,
uh,
you'll recall there.
It does make a difference how the thing is oriented.
Uh,
if it's,
uh,
less than edge on you see only part of the motion.
So it's,
uh,
helps a little to be close to edge on.
Now for the next method,
which are transits,
uh,
where the star gets in.
The way,
this criteria that you have to be edge on is much,
much more important because,
uh,
in the case of,
in the case of the radio velocity,
you know,
if you're not edge on,
it sort of gradually becomes a smaller and smaller and smaller effect.
But gradually,
there's no big,
uh,
moment where you can't see it at all.
But with transit,
uh,
if you're not edge on,
you don't see anything.
It's not that the effect gets smaller.
It's that the effect disappears all together.
If you're not sufficiently edge on so that,
uh,
the planet gets away,
gets in the way of,
of your line of sight to the star.
Uh,
this also favors short or small orbits.
but,
uh,
and that's because it has to be edge on how close to edge on you have to be
depends on how far,
uh,
the stars from the planet.
Here's what I mean.
Here's the star.
Uh,
and here's the,
here's you,
and supposing there's a planet here,
uh,
then,
then that will,
we'll just get in the way.
Uh,
but if there's a planet here,
a little further away on that same,
uh,
in the same kind of orbit,
only more distant,
then it doesn't get in the way.
And so,
uh,
more distant.
Uh,
let me phrase that differently.
Larger sent me major access makes it harder to have a transit you have to closer
to edge on.
If you were out here,
you'd have to see here anything within this,
uh,
this little angle here will cause a transit,
but if you're out here,
yeah,
let's see.
It would have to be anything within this smaller angle.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
It's just,
it's just the further away you hold your thumb from your eye,
uh,
the,
the less you have to move your arm,
uh,
to,
to cover a given thing.
All right.
Uh,
and also in this case for transits,
let's see.
The planet has to be large physically in terms of its size.
Uh,
and so it's not so much the mass,
but the size of the thing that matters.
So if you have a big butt light planet,
a big fluffy thing that'll work well for transits but not to welfare radial
velocities.
Then finally,
this astrometry method I just described,
uh,
favors large orbits in contrast to the other to affect,
it is irrelevant whether it's add on because,
uh,
if,
if it's a face on,
then the star goes round in a circle like this and you can see it.
If it's edge on the star goes round in a circle like this and you see it moving
back and forth as if it was in a line.
So you can do it either way.
Uh,
so that's irrelevant,
but has to be nearby,
must be nearby.
And like the radio velocity method,
you favor massive planets.
So these are,
uh,
three of the methods,
that are commonly being used now.
Yes.
Question.
That's the orbit has to be the strong imagery method so that the center of
masses are not far away.
Yes.
So the,
yes,
that's exactly right.
The orbit has to be large so that the center of mass has to be sufficiently far
away from the star.
So the travel's a big enough distance to be able to see.
That's exactly right.
Uh,
there's one more method that's commonly in use called a micro lensing,
which is really cool,
but I'm not going to talk about it,
uh,
because it's a relativistic method.
Uh,
and so we haven't talked about relativity yet.
We'll,
uh,
we'll cycle back and talk about this later on in the,
and this has actually worked.
And,
uh,
I will restrain myself from trying to explain it in the remaining 15 minutes of
this particular segment of the course.
We'll come,
we'll come back to it.
Uh,
but,
uh,
but this sort of set of selection effects is a good thing to know because then
if you do all of these things and you compare them to each other and each method
has a different selection effect,
then you have a fighting chance of figuring out what's actually out there rather
than what you are simply able to see because of the particular method you're
using.
So it's a good idea to be trying to do all of these things at once.
Okay.
Uh,
let me,
uh,
and this segment by talking about some space missions.
Yes.
Question.
There's similar to people of technology,
somewhat university cap c,
uh,
we can,
yes.
And so there,
if there's people elsewhere with our technology,
they can't detect the earth.
That is the same as saying we can't detect earths around other stars.
That is the case right now.
Uh,
however,
technology marches on,
uh,
and,
Alice,
I'll show you in 10,
15 years that may no longer be true.
So if the aliens out there are even 15 years further advanced than we are in
technology,
they might know that we're here.
Um,
other questions?
Yes,
yes.
Even supposing that we could detect the earth around another star,
would the presence of a more massive planet sort of,
ah,
would the presence of a more massive planet,
uh,
disrupt our potential detections of,
an earth like planet?
Not necessarily.
Remember I showed youth at the radio velocity curve where they had detected
several planets in the same system.
Uh,
what you do is you take the effect of the massive planet.
You figure out what the mass and orientation of the massive planet is,
and you remove that from your data,
and then you look for the little wiggles leftover.
And you could do that effectively with any of these methods.
The example I showed was the radio velocity thing where they were three
superposed sign curves,
but you could also do it.
There could be three different transit.
Uh,
and so you'd get a big lump for the big star and then a little lump for the
little star.
And if the little stars closer,
you'd get the more often.
And similarly in astrometry,
you could get it moving back and forth through to a massive planet.
And then emotion on top of that due to some other planets.
So,
uh,
for all of these cases,
the effect of one massive planet could be taken out so that you could see the
result.
Now what's perhaps more importantly is the presence of the massive planet could
screw up the orbit of the,
uh,
of the earth like planet,
this whole migration idea,
this Jupiter comes cruising into the inner solar system and then us earthlings
are in trouble because our orbit gets disrupted and we fall into the sun or
something like that.
So the bigger problem is not detecting it,
but whether it permits the planet to be there at all.
Other questions?
Yes.
Oh,
well you get your problem sets black.
Yes.
That's an easy question and of the class.
Other questions?
Yeah.
Will you be posting signs before?
We'll post these slides before the test.
Yes.
Yup.
All right,
good.
Thanks.
Other things?
Yes.
Why is it that we kind of like a,
it's not actually,
this was the bathroom is Junius geometry.
Why is it not to a,
because it's going from one side of the center of mass to the other.
Oh,
uh,
a is defined as the semi major access.
It's just a definition thing,
but isn't the star going?
Yes.
So the star travels a circle with radius egg.
So you're right,
it goes from one side to the other.
So the distance the star goes is,
is actually is actually to a,
and so that's just a definition question of,
because you can't,
you exhibits start with one.
Yes,
yes.
You're right.
So that the total angular change is,
you're right,
is actually to a,
and uh,
uh,
what I was,
what I was calculating there is the radius of the little circle that goes
around.
But you're absolutely right.
The,
the,
in fact the distance,
it's,
it's like for the radio velocity,
uh,
method,
the actual change in radio velocity,
it's from the peak to the trough.
But the number we quote is the amplitude of the sine curve.
So,
so you're right about them.
Other questions?
Okay.
Let me show you some things in work,
in progress and in particular space missions that are uh,
uh,
being planned to explore this further.
Yeah.
So the first of these is the so called Kepler mission,
uh,
which is,
going to look for transits.
I showed you the Hubble Space Telescope,
um,
uh,
transit curve,
which is much,
much better than anything you can do from the ground.
So obviously the place to look for transit is in space from space.
You could see transits the size of earth's,
uh,
of,
of planets,
the size of earth,
where from the ground you wouldn't be able to see that.
Uh,
and uh,
also.
And so what they want to do is sent up a mission that's going to do nothing but
make high precision measurements of stars in order to look for transit.
So the problem with the space telescope is everybody wants to use it for all
kinds of things.
There's relatively little limited amounts of time for any one particular
project.
It's also not perfectly designed for,
uh,
making these kinds of transits observations.
So this is going to be a mission,
which is,
uh,
set up for the express purpose of making very high precision measurements of the
brightness of stars over and over and over again.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the problem with this is just the general problem with transit that you only see
the ones that are edge on.
So you've got to look at lots and lots of stars.
Even if lots of them have planets,
you'll only see a few transits,
but this is designed to carry out that mission.
So they're going to be a lots of transits,
observe,
including transits from Earth,
uh,
from Earth size starts.
So this will be the first moment when this thing gets launched that will really
have a good handle on being able to detect an earth sized planet around.
So if the aliens have launched their equivalent of Kepler,
they're looking at us right now,
uh,
provided our solar system happens to be exactly edge on from their perspective.
This is due to launch in a year or two.
It's under construction.
It's ready to roll.
And this thing will be up in space,
taking data,
uh,
by the time,
within the next couple of years.
So that's an exciting thing to look forward to a little bit further into the
future is something called Sim.
This is the space interferometry mission.
Uh,
and this does astrometry,
uh,
and it's going to improve the accuracy of positions of stars from what we now
have,
which is in the Milly arc second range,
one 1000th of an arc second,
uh,
to the micro arc second range,
one,
1000000th of a,
uh,
of an arc second.
And again,
as we just did in that little calculation that will in principle enabled us to,
uh,
to look for,
earthlike systems.
Um,
now the limitation on this is that is this business that for astrometry,
you have to look at nearby stars,
uh,
and the nearer the star,
the better.
And,
and if you get far out into these,
into the galaxy,
then the method becomes less sensitive.
Uh,
it's also true that you know,
this method favors long orbits and space missions tend not to last for 40 years.
Uh,
and so if you're looking for Neptune,
which has,
you know,
uh,
many decade long orbit,
it's not clear that this is going to be around for long enough to actually make
those measurements.
So,
uh,
this astrometry thing is kind of squeezed between the requirement of the method
to have long orbits and the requirement of human beings to get results in a
relatively short amount of time.
Uh,
nevertheless,
this will be a,
a factor of a thousand improvement over what we can do from the ground.
This mission is authorized,
it's kind of under construction,
but it's one of those things where it's going to launch in five to seven years.
Uh,
that was also true five to seven years ago.
and it will probably be in on are pessimistic days.
We think it will still be true five to seven years from now.
It's always five years in the future,
both for technical reasons and for funding and political reasons.
Uh,
but,
uh,
there's some feeling that,
you know,
one of these days though,
the,
they'll actually get around to doing it,
but it's certainly further in the future,
uh,
than the Kepler mission is.
And then the great grand daddy of all,
uh,
planet mission to something called the terrestrial planet finder,
the TPF,
uh,
this is a NASA commitment,
and they want to directly image the planet.
So this is fundamentally different from everything else.
This is,
we're going to actually take a picture of the light from the planet.
We're going to give up this silly business of observing the star to infer the
presence of the planet.
We're actually going to look at the planet itself.
In order to do that,
you have to get rid of the light from the star.
You have to blank out the light of the star because otherwise as we saw a,
it'll drown out the planet.
And there are a couple of different ways you can do it.
Uh,
one is,
uh,
basically just masking.
You just put a big opaque thing somewhere in the optical path of the telescope
and it just blocks out the light of the star,
but it's carefully sized so that the light of stuff around it can still get in.
There are also more sophisticated,
uh,
optical methods,
something called interferometry,
which I won't explain right now.
Uh,
which can have the same effect of knowing out the light from the star.
And so you then observed the planetary light directly.
Uh,
the best way to do this is not an optical light,
but an infrared optical light.
Uh,
optical light is where stars give out most of their life.
Planet give out most of their light in the infrared.
You know,
you may be aware,
we all glow in the dark,
uh,
but we glow in the dark and the infrared,
that's why the military uses those interesting infrared goggles,
which turn everything green.
Uh,
what those do is they take infrared photons and,
uh,
they ingest infrared photons and they emit green light so that you can see
infrared.
And that's,
uh,
how they do these night vision goggles.
Uh,
and that's because at the temperatures on,
on ordinary planets,
we glow in the infrared,
which is why you don't see each other glowing in the dark,
uh,
because your eyes don't detect infrared.
But if you're going to be looking for planet,
you're much better off looking in the infrared than an ordinary life.
And then once you can see the light from a planet,
you get to do a really cool thing,
which is you get to examine the spectrum of that planet to find out what the
atmosphere is made of.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
we talked a little bit about spectral features which come from different atoms
or molecules.
Uh,
and,
uh,
once you actually see the light from the planet as opposed to the light from the
star,
you can actually study in detail what that stars,
what that planet's atmosphere is made of.
This by the way,
is how one goes about detecting low life on planet earth.
There was a very cute experiment a little while ago.
They were sending a mission to Jupiter,
the Galileo mission,
which is now at Jupiter doing science.
Uh,
but the way they did it was funny.
They sent it,
not outward toward Jupiter,
but inward toward Venus.
It took a swing around Venus.
It turns out if you do it right and you swing around a planet,
you can pick up extra speed.
And so to get this thing out to Jupiter,
they had it swing around Venus then come back to earth and swing around earth.
And each time it did one of these swings,
it picked up speed.
So it got to Jupiter actually faster that way.
A very clever bit of orbital dynamics.
But the consequence of it was that uh,
this mission,
one of our prime missions to look at other planets with all the various
instruments that we like to look at other planets with swung by near to Earth.
And so somebody had the very clever idea,
let's use our standard suite of exploration instruments and see if we can detect
the existence of life on earth using one of the satellites that we use to
explore the rest of the solar system.
And people had all kinds of thoughts about what would be detectable,
you know,
cities at night,
you would be able to see lights on the dark side,
the Great Wall of China,
you know,
you would be able to detect,
no,
turns out that the group,
that the strongest sign of life on earth is the fact that the atmosphere
contains methane.
Uh,
now the atmosphere of course is it has a lot of oxygen.
Methane,
you may recall is c h four a and if you put a little bit of methane into an
oxygen atmosphere,
it immediately dissociating.
You get water and carbon dioxide because of all the free oxygen.
So there shouldn't be any methane in the atmosphere,
but there is,
and you can detect it by looking at the infrared spectrum of the atmosphere.
Now what does it mean that there's methane in our atmosphere?
It means there's a continuous source of methane pumping into the atmosphere all
the time.
What is the source of that methane?
Uh,
it is as Carl Sagan delicately put it,
bovine flatulence,
uh,
cow farts.
Uh,
and,
and just digestion in general has a,
an output of methane,
which is continually piping into the atmosphere.
And if that weren't happening,
that happens from biological activity.
there wouldn't be any methane observable in the atmosphere.
So what you do is if you find some other planet is look at the atmospheric
chemistry and you see if there's something in there that's out of equilibrium
that could only be a continually replenished by biological activity and having
both oxygen and methane at the same time is one such one,
such indicators.
So the hope would be that we could not only see the light from the planet,
but we'd be able to detect the presence of biological activity as well.
So how do you go about doing this?
Bovine flatulence equals life,
uh,
words to live by.
Um,
let's see.
Uh,
so here's,
here's how you do it.
You need to have very high resolution.
You need to be able to separate the light from the star,
from the light,
from the planet to the greatest extent possible.
Turns out the way you do this is you have space telescopes spaced pretty widely
apart.
Uh,
that gives you the best handle on the resolution.
But they have to know where each other is to a precision very substantially
greater than the wavelength of the light that they're observing.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
so they need to be able to tell the distance apart of these things.
Too tiny fractions of a meter at pico meter metrology is the technical word.
Pico meter is 10 to the minus 12 meters.
Uh,
and metrology is just measuring how far apart you are.
So they need to be able to figure out to formation fly and know how far apart
they are too about uh,
the width of an atom or psalm.
Uh,
you want to image and the infrared mid infrared imaging wants you to pushes you
beyond Jupiter.
The problem is that inside the orbit of Jupiter,
there's all this warm dust in our own solar system and it's so,
it's like the sky is bright all the time from all the infrared emission from the
dust.
So you've got to go out into the colder parts of the solar system to do this.
Uh,
so we're,
what we're going to do,
the plan is you're going to build a half dozen or so things,
each of which is about 10 times the size of the space telescope.
We're going to move them out beyond Jupiter and formation,
fly them in this,
uh,
to this extremely high precision.
This is not something we're capable of doing right now.
Uh,
but there is a 25 year old,
25 years,
so-called roadmap of series of missions,
uh,
along the way,
which is going to simultaneously be good missions in their own right and develop
the technology.
Sam is one of these missions.
It's going to develop the high precision,
uh,
spatial imaging that you need for this.
Uh,
Jwst is the acronym for the next generation space telescope,
which is due to be launched in 2012.
Uh,
that's basically one such telescope,
but orbiting the earth.
That's a milestone.
And their various other milestones along this roadmap.
Uh,
and the hope is that in 25 years,
uh,
with,
you know,
25 to $50 billion,
we could actually do this thing.
And so here's the little artist's conception of these guys flying in formation
outside of the orbit of Jupiter.
That I guess this represents the sun down in the middle of the solar system.
They're looking out this way,
finding life on other planets.
And the big problem with this whole mission is that it's been canceled,
uh,
because a decision has been made that it's me.
You know,
this is very big expensive mission and the decision has been made that if you're
going to do something big and expensive,
you'll have to go to Mars instead,
put people on Mars instead.
However,
this is a 25 year timescale.
Things get canceled and canceled every three or four years.
Uh,
so,
uh,
who knows exactly what's going to happen.
And I think a,
this may reappear in the NASA plan at some point in the future.
And,
uh,
that's sort of the ultimate,
that people can think of now in terms of fine studying planets around other
stars.
Okay.
Uh,
that's when I got to say about this and a test on Thursday.